hi in this video i'll show you how you
can replicate data from an oracle
database
into bigquery using cloud data fusion's
replication
accelerator my name is rachel deakin
smith and i'm a developer advocate at
google cloud
if you're an etl developer or a data
analyst
you may want to continuously replicate
your operational data
into bigquery in real time so you can
make
timely data-driven business decisions
data fusion's wizard-driven accelerator
integrates with data stream
google cloud serverless and easy-to-use
change data capture service
this end-to-end cloud native solution
will fuel your analytic environment with
instant insights removing the need to
develop bespoke and high maintenance
solutions
so let's jump into the demo
creating a new replication job with
cloud data fusion is super easy
you first want to launch data fusion
from the cloud console
and you can find this under the big data
section if you don't have a cloud data
fusion instance yet you'll need to
create one
so you'll need to specify some basic
parameters such as the instance name and
the region
and you'll also need to add the
replication accelerator
you'll also need to make sure that both
the data fusion and data proc service
accounts
have the data stream admin role assigned
to them
and you can do this from the i am page
in the google cloud console
okay so once your instance is ready
you're now ready to configure
your oracle to bigquery replication so
we'll just click on the tile named
replicate
and then on the big green button
selecting create a replication job
setting up the replication is super easy
because we have a wizard driven ui that
will guide you through the entire
process
so you just need to provide a name and a
description
and then you can select the source
database type so while you can replicate
from mysql or sql server
we're interested in replicating from an
oracle source so we'll pick oracle by
data stream
and then we need to provide the source
connection details so we'll need to
enter the region
we need to provide the hostname and the
port we need to give a system identifier
and add any credentials that we need to
connect to our database
we also want to bring with us a
historical backfill so we'll leave the
replicate existing
data setting enabled
next you want to pick the source objects
so these are the tables and the columns
that you want to replicate
so for example in a given table we can
choose whether to replicate
all columns or to select a subset of
columns that we want to replicate
we can also choose the type of events to
replicate such as
inserts updates and deletes once we're
happy with our selection we can just
click next to configure the target
since cloud data fusion is fully
integrated with the rest of google
cloud's ecosystem
configuring the bigquery target is
pretty simple you just provide some
basic information such as the bigquery
dataset name
and you're ready to go you can actually
leave the dataset details blank to
default to the name of the source
database or schema
so we can click next to configure now
the advanced properties
so if you have a good idea on the amount
of data that you're planning to
replicate
you can tweak the replication
configuration here so for example how
much data you expect to replicate in an
hour
i'm happy with this as it is so i won't
make any changes
once the source and target details are
provided the replication wizard will
automatically perform a pre-deployment
assessment
and proactively advise you on any
potential issues
prior to the replication deployment so
for example it can point out any schema
compatibility issues between the source
and the target
and in this case the assessment has
indicated that we're missing a feature
so by clicking on the missing features
link i can drill down into the issue
and in this case realize that i'm
missing a primary key
so once i fix my problems in the source
i can just click the refresh button on
the top right corner
and move on to the summary page
after reviewing all the parameters
provided all that's left to do is click
the deploy replication job to start your
job
and once the replication is running
monitoring is super simple
you can natively monitor the replication
progress
the errors and the throughput and
latency via a centralized and easy to
use ui
and now once your data is in bigquery
you'll be ready to run real-time
analytics
or build a robust reporting platform by
connecting to business intelligence
services like looker
to build powerful real-time business
dashboards
ultimately allowing you to take
immediate actions based on streaming
data
so that's it i've quickly shown you how
to easily replicate data from an
oracle database into bigquery using a
wizard driven
cloud data fusion accelerator that is
integrated with google cloud
serverless and easy to use cdc offering
i hope you've enjoyed it so you can get
started from the google cloud console
or learn more at cloud.google.com
forward slash data hyphen fusion
thanks so much for watching